I don't know if you guys remember, but about
a year ago, there was a movement that called
itself, I guess, classical liberalism, which
claimed to be part of some new center of American
politics.
And in reality, it was a complete and total
ruse.
What they wanted to do was to sort of normalize
whacky libertarian conservatism as if it were
the new center of American politics when it
really wasn't the new center of American politics.
But just because that movement was wrong in
identifying a new center doesn't mean that
there isn't an identifiable new center.
And that's what I want to talk about today.
And I think the context that will be relevant
and interesting here is that if we on the
left want to keep moving ourselves to the
left as a country, we want to understand the
areas in which the average of the country
would be liable to side with us rather than
to be pulled further to the right.
Now, I don't know if this is necessary, but
as a quick disclaimer, before we jump into
this, this new center that I'm going to describe
to you.
These are not my views.
I need to I know that if I don't do this,
I will have 100 messages tomorrow from people
saying, David, you centrist shill.
It is I know we're not used to it with Donald
Trump, who's in who's unable to do any kind
of abstract thinking.
But I'm going to describe to you a set of
beliefs that is not mine.
So these are not my beliefs.
I'm to the left of this new center.
Now, that being said, let's get into the details.
Gallup did a very interesting study, which
they've done for 20 to 40 years on different
issues.
And they looked at where is the country right
now on a variety of different issues.
And they've represented the issues as well
as the shift in opinion visually.
And we're putting that up on the screen for
our visual audience.
But I'm also going to describe it to you.
And this lets us build up a sort of picture
of where the middle is right now in America.
On a number of issues.
So let's go through the eight issues.
So on.
On gun sales, the center, the average of the
country right now, the middle wants more strict
gun sales laws than those that we've had in
the past.
The center believes that religion is fairly
important, but not very important.
The center thinks that military spending is
about right, believes the earth should be
prioritized over the economy and that immigration
law should more or less stay the same in terms
of the number of immigrants coming into the
United States.
The center, as of today, thinks that the federal
income tax is just about right.
They don't think it should be raised, but
they don't think it should be lowered, that
abortion should be legal sometimes, but not
always, and that marijuana should be legalized.
So remember, this is just an average of the
middle.
But what's extremely interesting about this
is that it proves that the new center is not
libertarian.
It is not classically liberal.
And you really need to look at the details
to understand this new center as an example.
If the new center were merely libertarian,
it wouldn't favor stricter gun laws, for example.
It wouldn't favor prioritizing the earth over
the economy because that is code for.
We've got to regulate business activity.
If the center were libertarian, it wouldn't
think immigration laws were just about right.
Because true libertarians want total mobility
of labor, and that's not what we currently
have.
What's also important to understand about
how we came to this new center is how opinion
on these eight issues has shifted over time.
So, again, looking at one example, in the
early 90s, much of the gun laws should be
made more strict.
That changed until 2010, when people wanted
looser and looser gun laws.
And then since 2010, we've seen a reversal
which has very strongly returned to the early
90s numbers where the center wants stricter
gun laws.
So does the left as well.
Religion has been much more steady and it's
change over time.
The center of America has found religion less
and less important over time, where it now
finds it fairly but not very important.
Military spending has moved pretty radically,
often in concert with what's going on militarily
at the time.
And then, interestingly, if you look at the
trends on immigration, it is very steady over
the last 40 years that immigration to the
United States should show, generally speaking,
be increased.
Ending up sort of that it's okay where it
is and then probably not surprisingly, on
marijuana.
It's been a steady increase in the proportion
of Americans that believe cannabis should
be.
Legalized.
So why do we care about this again?
If we want to build the left, we must understand
where the center is.
If we misunderstand where the center is, we
are not going to properly structure our platform.
The center is not some small government, pro-business,
conservative.
The way we would sometimes be be convinced
Mitt Romney is not the center.
Mitt Romney is far more reasonable than Donald
Trump.
Mitt Romney is far less offensive and dangerous
than Donald Trump.
But Mitt Romney is not the center.
And that's important to understand.
When the left thinks the center is something
that it's not.
It tries to appeal to the center in the wrong
ways.
So let me know what you think.
I think that this new center represents a
lot of the changes we've been following in
the United States, which would include a sort
of status quo perspective on some issues and
a progressive ization on other issues.
Let me know what you think.
Let me know, importantly, how you think our
understanding of this new center could be
used to bring more people, tourists to our
side and to really push progressive change